Greetings to my 3ABN family and welcome
to another 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. My name
is Ricky Carter and I'll be your host.
We've got another hourpacked program
with your Bible questions. And you know
what? We've got the answers right here
in the word of God of which our
panelists will be sharing those answers
with us. So matter of fact, why don't
straight away let me just introduce you
to our panelists. To my right, I have
Sister Shelley Quinn. Welcome, sister.
It's a joy always to be on Bible Q&A and
we thank you for sending in your
questions. It's interesting as you look
at these and try to answer them in a
balanced way in such a short time.
>> Yes. Yes. Amen. Amen. And then next to
her have my brother, Pastor James
Rafferty. Welcome, sir.
>> Good to be here, Ricky, and to join
Shelley. Looking forward to answering
these questions. We've got some
challenging ones today, that's for sure.
But we got a little bit more time.
>> Amen. Amen. Yes. All right. Well, you
know, before we actually get into
reading God's word, we need to start off
with a word of prayer. So, Pastor James,
could you lead us in a word of prayer,
please?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
>> Father in heaven, just want to thank you
right now for this opportunity to lift
up our hearts to heaven. Want to thank
you for each one of the viewers, for
each question. Want to thank you for the
gift of the Holy Spirit that you
promised to lead us, to teach us, to
instruct us, to anoint us. We pray for
that anointing right now on us and also
on those that are listening. Open our
hearts and minds. Speak to us, we pray.
Make it practical and close. Help us to
have a closer walk with you. Yes.
>> In Jesus name.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, Shel, I've got your
first question. But before I give that
to you, let me remind our viewers at
home how you can participate. You can do
so one of three ways. You can send us
your questions via email to
bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
Or you can text us your questions to
618-2283975.
That's 618-2283975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions that way. Instagram, you can
send it to 3ABN
official. at 3ABN official. And then
also I want to let you know if you're
watching us right now on YouTube, could
you please hit that like button? And if
you're watching and you haven't been
haven't subscribed to our channel,
please subscribe to our channel right
now. That really helps us to grow this
channel. All right, Sister Shelley.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Here's your first question.
>> Luke chapter 8 says, "Seven demons were
cast out of Mary.
Who or what were those demons? That's
from Frank in California who emailed
that to us.
>> Frank, this is a great question and I
want to make an important distinction
between demonic oppression and demonic
possession.
So oppression is when a person is
harassed or influenced by evil spirits,
but they still remain in control of
their mind and their choices. And we can
think of several examples quickly. We
know that Job, especially Job chapter 1
and two, shows us how how intensely Job
suffered by oppression, but he never
lost control of his will. And in 2
Corinthians 12:7, Paul had the thorn in
his flesh. But he said it was a
messenger of Satan sent to buffet him,
to oppress him. Matthew 4, we could even
say Jesus temptation in the wilderness
shows oppression.
Satan attacked him but never controlled
him. On the other hand, possession,
if it's demon possession, it involves
direct control and domination by evil
spirits where a person is in such
spiritual bondage that they need
deliverance. So a clear example in the
Bible is Mark chapter 5, the demoniac.
He had totally lost control,
self-control and had to be freed by
Christ. Now let's come to Mary
Magdalene.
Luke 8 verse 2 and Mark 16 verse 9 says
Jesus cast seven demons out of her. You
know, it's interesting because scripture
doesn't describe behavior in Mary like
in some of the other cases of
possession, but it does j say Jesus cast
them out. So that language points to
possession,
>> not just oppression.
In scripture, the number seven is the
number of completeness.
And it likely means that Mary was in
deep spiritual bondage, not necessarily
that she'd committed seven specific sins
and not that each demon had a known
identity. The Bible is completely silent
about what those demons were. doesn't
name them or describe them individually.
So we have to be careful not to
speculate beyond what scripture says.
What can we say first? They were real
evil spirits. They were the fallen
angels. Ephesians chapter 6 and verse 12
reminds us that we wrestle against
spiritual hosts of wickedness.
Revelation 12 and verse 9. identifies
Satan and his fallen angels as
deceivers.
So that's first. Second, Mary's
condition was serious. It was seven
demons, a number of completeness. But
Christ's deliverance was also complete.
>> When Jesus set her free, she was fully
restored. And this leads to one of the
most important points. The Bible's focus
is not on the demons. The Bible's focus
is on Christ's power over them. So Luke
4:36, people were watching him heal and
they said, "With authority and power, he
commands the unclean spirits and they
come out." And after her deliverance,
Mary Magdalene became one of Jesus most
devoted followers. She was present at
the cross. She was present at the tomb.
And she was the first to see the risen
savior. So the best biblical biblical
conclusion is this. Mary Magdalene had
been possessed by real evil spirits.
Scripture doesn't identify them.
Instead, it highlights the far greater
truth. No matter how deep the bondage,
Jesus has the power to set people free.
Amen. John 8:36 says, "If the Son has
set you free, you shall be free indeed
indeed." Amen. Thank you, sister.
Love it that we can be free indeed in
Christ. All right, Pastor James, here's
your first question.
Can you please explain Judges 11 34-4?
That's from Eva who emailed that to us.
>> Thank you, Eva, for that question. in
Judges 11:40 or 34 to 40. Let's start
just by reading the text. And before I
start though, I want to just mention
Shelley, I really appreciated the
difference there between oppression and
possession. That really gave some great
clarity uh to my mind. Okay, going back
to our text, Judges 11 for Eva 34 to 40.
And Jeepa came to Mispa unto his house.
And behold, his daughter came out to
meet him with timberalss and dances, and
she was his only child. Beside that he
had neither son nor daughter. And it
came to pass when he saw her that he ran
his clothes, and he said, "Alas, my
daughter. Oh, thou has brought me very
low. Thou art one of them that troubles
me, for I have opened my mouth unto the
Lord, and I cannot go back." And she
said unto him, "My father, if thou has
opened thy mouth unto the Lord, do to me
according to that which proceedth out of
thy mouth, for as much as the Lord has
taken vengeance for thee on thine
enemies, even of the children of Ammon."
And she said unto her father, "Let this
thing be done for me. Let me alone two
months that I may go up and down upon
the mountains and bewail my virginity. I
and my fellows." And he said, "Go." And
he sent her away. And for two months she
went with her companions and bewailed
her virginity upon the mountains. And it
came to pass at the end of two months
that she returned to her father who did
with her according to his vow which she
had vowed. And she knew no man. And as
it was custom in Israel, the daughters
of Israel went yearly to lament the
daughter of Jeepa the Gileadite for four
days in the year. So that's Judges
11:30-31 or excuse me 34 to to 40. Now
verses 30 to31 are probably keyed to the
question and they say this that Jeepa
made a vow to the Lord and said if you
will give the Ammonites into my hand
then whatever comes out from my doors
the doors of my house to meet me when I
return in peace from the Ammonites shall
be the Lord's and I will offer it for a
burnt offering. There are two options to
understand the story. Option number one
would be that he was going to sacrifice
his daughter or kill her as an offering
to God. Now, we can know that that's not
what happened um for at least two
reasons. Number one, the seventh
commandment forbids uh killing. Now,
thou shalt not murder or kill. Exodus
20:13. And number two, child sacrifices
were also forbidden by God. And that's 2
Kings chapter 16 and verse three. Now
the second option is that this devout
father gave his daughter to the service
of God forever without any option of her
having a marriage or having children.
And this appears to be from the text
this appears to be the case because
her virginity was bewailed not her life
by her friends not her physical life.
And we know when we go to Numbers, for
example, Numbers 3:es 11-13, the Levites
were taken in the place of a burnt
offering to serve the Lord forever. In
fact, when we look at the text again and
read them carefully, we can understand
that this was the vow that Jeepa made.
Now, let's just read the text again,
verses 30 and 31 of Judges 11. And Jeepa
made a vow to the Lord and said, "If you
will give the Ammonites into my hand,
then whatsoever comes out from my from
the doors of my house to meet me when I
return in peace from the Ammonites shall
be the Lord's." Stop right there. That's
the vow that he's making now. He's
probably thinking a servant's going to
come out to meet him. He doesn't know
his only child is going to come out to
meet him, but he makes a vow that that
person that comes out, because he's
talking about coming out of the house of
his doors, he's not talking about the
barn or, you know, the cattle. He's
talking about coming out of the house of
his doors. That person is going to be
given to the Lord forever and I'm going
to offer a burnt offering. Now,
sometimes we assume from that and I'm
going to offer that person as a burnt
offering. But I believe the text is
saying, I'm going to devote that person
whoever meets me to the Lord forever and
I'm going to offer a burnt offering.
That's the way I read the text. So, I
hope that helps Eva to answer your
question.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you for that answer.
Sure. That helped to answer mine as
well. All right.
Okay. Well, Shelley, I've got another
question for you. Number two here.
Why do people always refer to the coming
of God's return as the second coming of
Christ? That's from Mike in Michigan who
emailed that to us.
My reason people refer to God's return
as the second coming of Christ is
because the Bible specifically reveals
that the divine person who will visibly
return is Jesus Christ, the Messiah, the
hope of all ages, Jesus who is also the
Christ who is fully God. Matthew 1:23
says, "The virgin, the virgin shall bear
a child, and his name will be Emmanuel,
God with us." John 1:1, "In the
beginning was the word, the word was
with God, and the word was God." John
1:14 identifies that word. He became
flesh and dwelt among us. In Colossians
2 and verse 9, in Paul says, "In Christ
dwells all the fullness of the Godhead
bodily." The Messiah Christ was God
clothed in humanity as the person of
Jesus Christ. He was fully divine yet
fully human. Philippians 2 6-8's the
best argument for that. Christ was the
member of it shows us he was a member of
the Godhead equal with the father and
that the Lord of glory stepped out of
heaven and humbled himself to take on
human flesh to become the person of
Jesus Christ and to die as a sin
offering for our sins on the cross. 1
Corinthians 2 and verse 8, Paul said
that if they'd known the true story,
they would not have crucified
the Lord of glory. So Jesus,
God came down, the second person of the
Godhead came down to become a human
being, take on flesh and to become the
person of Jesus Christ, the covenant son
of God. We see that the New Testament
identifies the person of the Godhead who
returns as Jesus Christ himself. Acts
1:11, the angels told the disciples who
are watching Christ ascend. This same
Jesus who was taken up from you into
heaven will so come in like manner as
you saw him go into heaven. You know,
people miss this so much. So often
Christ once God took on our humanity and
became the person of Jesus Christ, he
returned
to
uh heaven
>> as still a human and God. So those two
natures have been blended together
forever. He took glorified flesh back to
heaven. But Jesus promised to return
again in John 14:3. He said, "I will
come and receive you to myself." So the
Messiah came first in the humility as
our savior. And it's called the second
coming of Christ because he's coming
second in the power and glory as a king.
>> The Bible connects God's Christ return
with language that the Old Testament
uses for God himself. Isaiah 40:10,
behold the Lord God shall come. Isaiah
35:4, behold your God will come. He will
come and save you. And the New Testament
shows that those promises are fulfilled
in Christ. Titus 2:13
calls it the blessed hope and glorious
appearing of our great God and Savior
Jesus Christ. And Revelation 1:7 says
that when he comes, every eye will see
him.
>> Let me just add this real quickly. I've
been doing refreshing myself on the
study of light. Did you know light
travels at 186,000
miles per second, right? Not per hour,
right?
>> 186,000 miles per second. The
circumference of the world is around
24,900.
Light could circle the world almost
eight times in the blink of an eye in a
second. When he returns with clouds, he
God is light. He's going to circle this
like lightning. He Jesus said from east
to west. Every eye will see him.
>> Amen.
>> In the blink of an eye.
I love that. Looking forward to that
day. All right. Thank you, sister. All
right, Pastor James, here's your second
question. What does Genesis chapter 49
verses 2- 27 mean for the tribes in the
last days? That's from Jamal in New York
who texted that to us.
Thank you for your question, Jamal.
That's a great question. We go to
Genesis chapter 49 and we see the
blessings that are pronounced upon his
children, basically the 12 tribes of
Israel. There's one specific tribe that
I'm going to focus on to answer this
question in the short time that we have.
And that's going to be the tribe of
Adan. It's in Genesis 49 16 and 17. And
out of this particular these particular
verses, we're going to build a whole I
think uh significant meaning for each
one of us in these last days because I
think you're referring to the connection
between Genesis 49 and Revelation
chapter 7 where God's people are sealed
and they're likened under the 12 tribes
of Israel. Of course, that's talking
about spiritual Israel according to
James 1 and verse one, the 12 tribes
scattered abroad, those who are
believers in Jesus Christ. Here's
something interesting. In Revelation 7,
the tribe of Dan is missing. It's not
there. Now, there are still 12 tribes
that are going to be sealed. However,
the tribe of Dan is replaced by the
tribe of Manasseh.
>> And what we're looking at here is the
spiritual significance of that transfer
that that uh replacement by the tribe of
Manasseh. And we can only find that as
we go back to the story of the Bible.
The story of the Bible begins in Genesis
49 with this description of Dan. He is
described in verse 16 as a judge of his
people as one of the tribes of Israel.
The word Dan actually means judge or to
judge. And the word Danielle means God
is judged. And then in verse 17 it says,
"Dan shall be a serpent by the way and
add her in the path that bites the horse
heels so that his rider shall fall
backwards." Dan is a backbiter. Dan is
like the serpent. The serpent is
described in Revelation 12 and 11 as an
accuser of the brethren. And we're told
that we're to overcome the accuser of
the brethren by the blood of the lamb.
So we see here the characteristic of Dan
being a serpent, a backbiter, a judge
that cannot be sealed with the seal of
God because the seal of God is the
character of God. Right? And if we're
going to be like God, we've got to let
God through the Holy Spirit get rid of
all of our bitterness and backbiting and
criticism and faultf finding and
judging.
>> So who replaces Dan and why does he
replace Dan? This is the question. And
the answer is so powerful in the context
of Revelation and of course the story in
Genesis of Joseph and his sons because
the person or the tribe that replaces
the tribe of Dan in Revelation is
Manasseh. Now Manasseh was Joseph's
firstborn son, right? And according to
Genesis 41 and verse 25, the reason why
Manasseh replaced uh excuse me, the
reason why Joseph called Manasseh,
actually it's Genesis 41 and verse 51.
The reason why Joseph called his
firstborn son Manasseh was because he
says, "God has caused me to forget all
of my u bad memories in my father's
house." I'm living there a little bit.
But he it this verse specifically says
all of my toil. Basically, all of my
troubles. The troubles that specifically
he's talking about is the fact that his
brothers sold him into slavery. That's
what happened to Joseph. His brothers
sold him into slavery. And this uh agony
that he went through of being sold into
slavery by his brothers, dispossessed
and really left to die, so to speak. uh
this was a burden on his heart until he
realized that God's hand was in this and
that God was working this out. As it
says in Romans 8:28, "All things work
together for good to those who love God
to the called according to his purpose."
God was working this out for deliverance
not only for Joseph, but for all of his
family. And we see this come to light in
uh chapter 45 of Genesis. Joseph talks
about this in verses 5, 7, 8, and 9. He
basically says to his brothers who are
worried about him uh taking their lives
as revenge. He says, "I don't have any
bitterness. I don't have any judgmental
thoughts. I'm not going to be like the
serpent. God overruled this. God is the
one that led me to Egypt. God is the one
that sent me forth to preserve life. My
life is in God's hands and God is the
one that has worked this out." Amen. So,
this is huge for us because in the last
days, God's people who are sealed with
the seal of God are going to have to
overcome judgmental, critical,
backbiting, serpent-like attributes with
the forgiveness and the forgetfulness of
Joseph and Manasseh. That's the picture
that God is bringing. You know, many
times we argue about Revelation 7
>> and 144,000. Is it a literal number? Is
it a spiritual number? I think that's
all a side uh issue. Satan is trying to
get us diverted into theological
arguments about a number when the real
message in Revelation 7 is the character
that God wants us develop. And the story
of Joseph and how we can trust God to
overrule all of our heartache, all of
our sorrow, all of our pain, even the
most uh the treason from closest people
to us. We can trust God to overrule that
and we can put our lives in his hands.
>> Amen, brother. Amen.
>> I love that answer. Beautiful.
>> Amen. Me, too. Thank you, sir.
>> All right. Praise God. Well, Shel, I've
got your third question, but let me
remind our viewers how they can
participate. You can do so one of three
ways. You can send us an email to
bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
Or you can text in your questions to
618228-3975.
That's 618-2283975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions in that way at 3ABN official
at 3ABN official. Okay, Sister Shelley,
here we go. Are there sins that would
require a baptized Christian to be
rebaptized? That's from Trudy in New
York who texted that to us.
>> Trudy, thank you for this question. It
is a very important question because
many Christians, sincere Christians,
struggle with this. Baptism is a sign
that we are entering into a covenant
relationship with Jesus Christ. It is a
public confession that we have given our
lives to Christ. We want to walk with in
newness of life with him. But is it's
not intended to make us fear every time
we stumble. The Bible does not teach
that every sin we commit after baptism
requires rebaptism. If that were the
case,
every believer would be starting over
again and again and again. But praise
God, that's not how he deals with his
children. When we're baptized and we
fall, the answer is not automatically re
being rebaptized. The answer is
confession and repentance and returning
to Jesus. First John 1:9, if we confess
our sins, he is faithful and just to
forgive us our sins and cleanse us of
all unrighteousness.
And 1 John 2:1 says this, that if anyone
sins, he's writing to believers. We have
an advocate. That's the comforter.
That's the pariclete. Jesus Christ was
the pariclete. The Holy Spirit is
another pariclete just like him. But it
says we have an advocate with the father
Jesus Christ the righteous. So ordinary
sins after baptism call for confession
and repentance. The issue is not what
single sin automatically
requires rebaptism. The real issue is
whether there has been such a serious
departure from Christ
>> or such a new and decisive recon
conversion experience
>> that rebaptism becomes a fitting
>> um public testimony of a renewed
covenant.
Sometimes a person may have quit
following in Christ's footsteps of
righteousness and lived in open
rebellion and by their actions they
publicly denied him.
>> Later they may come back through a real
recon conversion experience.
Maybe they've committed open apostasy or
deliberate abandonment of faith or a
profound return to Christ after
seriously backsliding. This would make
rebaptism
appropriate as a meaningful public
confession that you're rededicating your
life to Christ. But not every struggle
is rebellion and not every every failure
is apostasy.
Sometimes a believer loves the Lord,
falls short, feels broken over their
sin, and all they need is to experience
the cleansing grace of Christ. Again,
>> Jesus pictures this in John 13:10. He
says, "The one who is bathed
needs only to wash his feet." And so in
other words, he's kind of saying those
who belong to him, we still need daily
cleansing
>> as we walk through this world. But most
sins after baptism, what we need is not
another baptism, just a fresh surrender
to the Lord.
>> The key issue is not just going back
into the water. The key issue is whether
the heart is fully returning to Christ.
Another time when rebaptism
may be appropriate, we see this in Acts
19 1-7. Paul found baptized disciples of
Christ in Ephesus, but they never even
heard of the Holy Spirit. And as he is
further explaining truth, they as they
receive fuller light, they were
rebaptized
because they had a new understanding of
what the plan of redemption really was.
>> Right. Right. Amen. Amen. Thank you,
sister, very much. Okay, Pastor James,
here's your third question.
Can you please explain Psalms 58:3?
Is this verse saying children are born
wicked from the womb? That's from Mercy
who emailed that to us.
Thank you for that question, Mercy.
Appreciate that. Psalm 53:3, the wicked
are estranged from the womb. They go
astray as soon as they are born,
speaking lies. So, the word that's used
here is the wicked. And it's an
interesting contrast with the righteous
all through the Old Testament. We lose
that contrast when we get to the New
Testament. Paul actually summarizes our
condition uh from birth in Romans
chapter 3 and he includes
believers and unbelievers, Jews and
Gentiles in that contrast. Let's just
take a look at it here. We're going to
look at Romans chapter 3 and we're going
to start with verse 9. Romans 3 and
verse 9. It says, "What then? Are we
better than they?" That is, "Are we
Jewish believers, followers of God? Are
we better than they, the Gentiles who
don't know God?" Uh, and then he goes on
to say this, "No, in no wise, for we
have before proved, both Jew and
Gentile, that they are all under sin. As
it is written, there is none righteous,
know not one. There is none that
understands. There is none that seeks
after God. They are all gone out of the
way. They are alltogether become
unprofitable. There is none that does
good, know not one. Their throat is an
open suppler. Their tongues have used
deceit. The poison of asps is under
their lips. Verse 14, whose mouth is
full of cursing and bitterness. Their
feet are swift to shed blood.
Destruction and misery are in their
ways. Verse 17, the way of peace they
have not known. Verse 18, there is no
fear of God before their eyes. Now we
know that whatsoever things verse 19 the
law says it says to them who are under
the law that every mouth may be stopped
and all the world may become guilty
before God. So the human family is
selfish by nature. I think that that's a
more appropriate word for us to
understand. We're selfish by nature
because everyone can relate to that. And
the verses we just read which are found
all through the New Testament. The
verses we just read are basically
telling us about this selfish nature
that we have. It's only the grace of God
that pulls us away from our natural
selfishness. Every child, every baby is
born selfish except as they are
influenced by the Holy Spirit. We might
say, well, how does that relate to
Jesus? Wasn't he born uh as a man? Was
he selfish? Well, when we look at the
way that Christ was born, we recognize
according to Luke 1:35 that Jesus was
born by the uh under the shadow of the
Holy Ghost, right? We might say that
Jesus was born of the Holy Ghost and
Mary, that Joseph wasn't actually his
father. And Jesus speaks to this need,
this reality in John chapter 3 and:e
three. He says to Nicodemus who was a
religious leader uh prominent and
someone that everyone looked up to and
experenced
we might call him a professor or you
know a theological um you know uh person
of our day. Jesus said to Nicodemus you
need to be born again. Verily verily I
say unto you unless you're born again
you won't even see the kingdom of God.
So the born again experience is vital
for us. Jesus was we could say Jesus was
born born again. And we know John the
Baptist was filled with the Holy Spirit
from his mother's womb according to
Lukeap 1:15. That means that the Holy
Spirit was drawing him away from the
inherent selfishness that he would
receive from both parents. Jesus of
course is born of the Holy Spirit. So he
has the Holy Spirit drawing him right
from the from the his conception drawing
him to follow and serve God. He always
surrendered his will to God. We don't
always do that. And so the opposite of
surrender to God is selfishness.
>> So just to answer your question more
directly uh
is is there evil that grows from within
us even as we're born as children? Yes.
It's called selfishness. And only the
Holy Spirit can rescue us, can draw us
away, can renew us, and can destroy that
selfishness in our hearts.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, sir.
All right, Mr. Shelley, here's your
fourth question. How can we live in
heaven if we are constantly reminded of
the sins that put the nail prints in
Jesus' hands? That's from one of our
viewers in Tennessee who texted that to
us.
>> I wish I knew your name because I want
to thank you for this heartfelt
question.
>> Yes, the marks of Jesus Christ, the
Bible says, will remain. You know, after
his resurrection, Jesus still bore the
wounds of Calvary. Calvary. We see in
John 20 and verse 27 that he said to
Thomas, "Reach your finger here. Look at
my hands." Those scars are not signs
that heaven will be filled with sorrow,
but they will be return eternal
reminders of the greatness of God's love
and the price that he paid for our
redemption.
>> Right? The Bible shows that heaven will
not be a place of crippling guilt, but
of redeemed understanding, perfect love,
and everlasting gratitude.
The difference in heaven, we're not, we
won't look at Christ wounds through the
lens of condemnation
because we'll be looking through the
lens of complete salvation. Mhm.
>> Right now, sin brings grief, guilt, and
sorrow, and shame, and struggle because
we still live in a fallen world, and we
battle with our own weakness. But in
heaven, sin will rise no more.
>> Amen.
>> And the redeemed will stand fully
forgiven. Amen. Fully cleansed, fully
transformed.
Romans 8:1 says this, "There is
therefore no condemnation for those who
are in Christ Jesus." That's right here
and now. If you're living in Christ,
there is no condemnation. How much more
when we get to heaven will this be a
true statement. First John 3:2 says, "We
know that when he is revealed, we shall
all be like him, for we shall see him as
he is." So heaven's not a place where
the saved continue under a cloud of
great guilt.
>> Right?
>> We It's going to be a place where Christ
work in us is complete. Revelation 21:4
said, "God will wipe away every tear
from their eyes. There shall be no more
death, nor sorrow, nor crying."
It means we're not going to be
emotionally tormented by the memory of
sin. The sorrow of this world will be
gone. Hallelujah.
>> Amen.
>> Will we remember what Jesus has done for
us?
>> Absolutely. That's why sin's never going
to rise again in my mind.
>> In fact, that memory will deepen our
worship. We see in Revelation 5:9, it
pictures the redeemed singing, "You are
slain and you have redeemed us to God by
your blood."
>> So, we are going to be very worshipful.
The cross will never be forgotten,
>> but it'll not produce despair.
It will produce praise.
>> Amen.
>> Think of it this way. The nail prints in
Jesus' hands will for forever testify
that not only are we loved by God, but
we're accepted by God.
>> And they're they will not reopen the
pain of guilt, right?
>> Because guilt has been removed by his
blood.
>> They will instead magnify his mercy, his
justice, and his grace. We're not going
to be saying, "I'm still condemned."
We're going to be saying, "Worthy is the
lamb who was slain for me."
>> And I I wanted to give this reference.
Naam 1:9 tells us, "Affliction will not
rise
>> up a second time." Right?
>> So sin will never return. The scars of
Jesus will be the eternal assurance that
the great controversy is over and
redemption is secure forever.
>> Yes.
>> So how will we live in heaven while
seeing his scars, the nail prints in his
hands? Not in sorrowful shame,
>> right? but in joyful adoration. Yes.
>> Not crushed by memory, but overwhelmed
by grace, not haunted by sin, but
eternally secure
>> in love. The love of our savior. And
this is something we will remember that
his love conquered all. Those hands will
not break our heart in heaven.
They will anchor our heart to him
forever in love.
>> Amen. Thank you, sister. I remember how
Isaiah reminds us how we are we are
inscribed on the palms hands.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> All right, Pastor James, here's your
fourth question.
>> I've heard that if a person is divorced
and has remarried, they are still living
in adultery. even though they have asked
God to forgive them. Is this true?
>> Great question. You know, we're
referring probably we're looking here at
Matthew chapter 19. And if you just want
to take a look there, we'll look at a
few verses in Matthew 19. We'll look at
verses 3-9. Matthew chapter 19. The
Pharisees come to Jesus and they're
tempting him and they're saying to him,
uh, "Is it lawful for a man to put away
his wife for every cause?" Keep point
right there. for every cause. And he
Jesus answered and said unto them, have
you not read that he which made them at
the beginning made them male and female?
And he said and said, for this cause,
verse 5, shall a man leave father and
mother and shall cleave to his wife, and
they twain two shall be one flesh.
Wherefore they are no more twain two,
but one flesh. What therefore God has
joined together, Jesus continues to say,
let not man put aunder. Then they said
unto him, verse 7, and these are the
Pharisees again who are trying to tempt
him, trick him, why did Moses then
command to give a writing of divorcement
and to put her away? And he, Jesus says
unto them, Moses, because of the
hardness of your hearts, suffered you to
put away your wives, but from the
beginning it was not so. And I say unto
you, whosoever shall put his way his
wife except for fornication
and shall marry another commits
adultery. And whosoever marries her
which is put away also commits adultery.
Now these are probably the text. There
are others in the Bible, but these are
probably the text that you're referring
to in relation to uh being remarried or
being divorced and being remarried and
committing adultery. And Jesus here is
speaking to a specific issue because
among the Jews it was permitted for them
to put away their wives for the most
trivial offense trivial offenses like
even today we see that people get
divorced for whatever reason I'm I've
fallen out of love with you and God
allowed this in the history of the
Jewish nation because of their hardness
of heart but God's will for them God's
original purpose for for them was to
take them back to the to Eden to the
Garden of Eden or marriage was
instituted by God along with the seventh
day Sabbath and it was to be forever.
There was to be no divorce. There was to
be no separation. And so Jesus is trying
to take us back to that. God's ideal for
us is that we would stay married to one
person for the rest of our lives without
using triv trivial trivial excuses.
You know, meaningless excuses to
separate into divorce and marry someone
else for whatever reasons. Now, we know
in the Bible that all sin can be
forgiven. We're told, and Shelley
referenced this earlier in 1 John
chapter 1 and verse 9, if we confess our
sins, he's faithful and just to forgive
us our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. So, that would include
the sin of divorce. Forgiveness though
does not make sin okay. The sin of
divorce is not an exception to
forgiveness, but we don't want to turn
the grace of God into a license to sin.
Let me just say that again.
>> God can forgive us for divorce. God
doesn't say, "I'm going to forgive you
for all your sins except for divorce."
God can forgive us for divorce. But at
the same time, just because we know God
will forgive us, doesn't mean that we,
oh, well, let's just get a divorce. God
will forgive me. Right? That was the
attitude that the Pharisees had. That
was the hardness of heart that they had.
And Jesus didn't want them to have that
hardness of heart. He didn't want them
to have that attitude. And so he's
calling them, he's calling you and I
back to God's original purpose.
>> We don't want to turn the grace of God
in license to sin on the one hand, nor
do we want to frustrate the grace of God
on the other hand and not recognize that
God can indeed forgive us. And at the
same time, God wants us to continue with
that person that we've committed our
lives to. He wants marriage to be
between a man and a woman for all
eternity. Actually, throughout all
eternity, but definitely throughout our
life on this earth. I hope that helps
answer your question.
>> Amen. Amen. Good answer. Thank you, sir.
>> All right, Shel. Here's your last
question.
>> Okay. Romans 5:12 says, "Therefore, just
as through one man sin entered the
world, and death through sin, and thus
death spread to all men, because all
sinned." Paul explains that sin entered
the world through one man, Adam, and
salvation comes through one man, Jesus.
But wasn't it Eve who fell in the Garden
of Eden? Why does Paul say sin entered
the world through Adam? That's from
Jonathan in Nevada who emailed that to
us.
>> Jonathan, the Bible presents two Adams.
The first created man was the first
Adam. He was the representative head of
humanity and he is even called the son
of God in Luke 3:38.
The last Adam is the person of Jesus
Christ, God, who took upon human flesh
and became the new representative of
humanity as the covenant son of God.
Now, in 1 Corinthians 15:45, Paul
explains this. The first man, Adam,
became a living being. The last Adam,
Jesus Christ, became a lifegiving
spirit. So from the first Adam we
receive our natural life the and our
fallen human nature but from the last
Adam Jesus Christ we receive spiritual
life and ultimately the promise of a
glorified body at the resurrection.
>> So why does the Bible say that sin
entered through Adam when Eve sinned
first? Romans 5:12 says this, "Through
one man, sin entered the world and death
through sin." Adam was created before
Eve. Adam was created first. He stood as
the representative head of the human
family. Genesis 2:16 and 7 shows that
Adam received the covenant command not
to eat from the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil. Now, Eve, yes, sin first
in sequence, but Eve was deceived. 1
Timothy 2:14 says, "Adam was not
deceived, but the woman being deceived
fell into transgression." Adam's sin was
different. It was deliberate. He was not
deceived. He chose to break covenant
with God. He willingly chose to disobey.
And because he stood as the covenant
head of humanity,
his transgression carried representative
consequences for the entire human race.
Romans 5:19 says, "By one man's
disobedience, many were made sinners."
So Paul's point is not merely historical
order but representation.
Adam stands for fallen humanity. Christ
stands for redeemed humanity. In 1
Corinthians 15:22
it says as in Adam all die, even so in
Christ when you are in Christ all shall
be made alive. So through Adam came sin,
condemnation and death. But through
Christ comes grace and justification and
life. And that is what makes the gospel
so beautiful. The same Bible that tells
us ruin came through the one man Adam
also says salvation comes through that
last Adam, the one man, Jesus Christ.
And one of my favorite scriptures,
Romans 5:17.
If by the one man's offense, death
reigned through the one, much more those
who receive the abundance of grace will
reign in life through the one Jesus
Christ.
>> Amen.
>> Adam explains why the human race fell.
Christ explains how the human race can
be redeemed. Amen.
Redeemed. How I love to proclaim it.
>> Amen.
>> Thank you, sister.
>> All right, Pastor James, here's your
final question. What does the bank in
Matthew 25:27 refer to? How do you
deposit? That's from Senate and Curacal
who emailed that to us.
>> Curacal. Wow, you said that really well,
Ricky. Now, which which version of
redeemed are you singing there?
Redeemed. how I love the proclam
redeemed. How
>> vote number one was
>> this question really made me think and I
had to do a lot of study on this. So I'm
just going to uh u
share a little bit of a pre on this and
that is uh these are some thoughts that
I came up with that I uh hope will be
helpful in answering this question but
uh I'm not saying that this is the
theolog
27. says, "Thou thoughtest therefore to
have thou oughtest therefore to put my
money to the exchangers and then at my
coming I should have received my own
with usery or with interest and that's
the ESV uh English translation of this
verse says that you should have invested
your money with the bankers and then I
would have had interest or usery uh at
my coming." So the banker the word
banker there is a money broker or a
banker. I liken that in Malachi chapter
3:10 to the treasury of the storehouse
of God. And so I think that in Malachi
3:10, it talks about how we've been
robbing God by not giving back to him
that which is his. Now, I'm talking
about the tithe here because the tithe,
the tenth, is God's. And we don't give
God something when we give him a tithe.
We return tithe to him. So it's God's.
And if we don't return it to him, we're
actually robbing him because he claims
it as his as a testimony that everything
we have comes from him. The tenth
reminds us that everything we have is
his and the tenth therefore is his. So
if we don't want to increase God's
kingdom ourselves, we should at least
give God what belongs to him. And this
servant, this one talent servant uh did
not want to increase God's kingdom. And
he robbed God. He robbed the storehouse.
He robbed the treasury. He robbed the
exchanges. He robbed the bank. He robbed
those who kept the money so that they
could use it, God's money, so they could
use it uh to gain interest for God.
>> So I'd say the bank would represent the
place where our talents can make a
different for difference for God's
kingdom. And when the servant was told
that the least he should have done was
given his one talent to the bank or to
the exchangers, I think it's referring
to allowing God to receive even the
smallest amount of benefit of all that
he has given that one talent servant.
All that he has given each one of us.
Every single person has at least a
talent, something that God has given to
them. Now the one talent servant buried
his talent in the earth, that is in
earthly things rather than heavenly
things. He didn't even use the smallest
gift that God had given him to enlarge
God's kingdom. We could say that he
didn't even support the work of God with
his finances. That could have been the
least he could have done. And I think
that 3ABN would really appreciate people
supporting the work of God with their
finances because this is how the gospel
is taken to the world and this is how
people are saved for all eternity,
right? It takes finances to do that. And
God, Jesus is speaking to that in this
um story. He's speaking to more than
just money. Of course, he's speaking to
all of our talents. But the minimum that
we should give to God is what he's
already given to us that really belongs
to him. So, we may not feel that we can
be missionaries or we can give Bible
studies or we can go doortodoor or that
we can even give a testimony for God. We
may be shy and you know, but the least
we could do is support his work and give
back to him what he's given to us so
that it can increase with interest.
Right? Instead, the servant goes and
buries his talent in the earth. And the
earth of course again represents this
world. He didn't give back to God what
was his but he buried his talent in the
things of this world in investments in
his future in retirement in toys
whatever it was you know pleasure rather
than giving God uh that which really
belongs to him. So when we bury our
talent in earthly things we refuse to
let God have the least part of what he's
given us. And if we give God our one
talent, at least give it to the bankers,
the storehouse, the exchangers, we allow
it to gain some interest in supporting
the work of God.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you. Thank you. Hey,
we're getting ready to take a short
break, but before you go, just want to
let you know if you're watching us on
YouTube right now and you were blessed
by all these answers, please leave us a
comment. It really helps to support this
channel. Hey, we'll be right back. Don't
go away.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-2283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch 3 Bible Q&A for
answers from God's word. Our time's
almost up. Let's get a final thought.
Anybody have a final thought?
>> I do. I wanted to say, you know, Christ
is fully God. We see in Hebrews 1:8, the
father, God, is speaking to the son. And
here's what he says. Your throne, oh
God, is forever and ever. So the one who
came first in the time in the
incarnation is going to come the second
time in glory. The one who died to
redeem us as our lamb is the one who
serves as our high priest. And he is
returning as the king of kings.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen.
>> Well, thank you very much for joining
us. Want to leave you with a fun
scripture song from Matthew 4:E4.
It is written,
"Man shall not live by bread alone, but
by every word that proceedth out of the
mouth of God." Remember, continue to
hide God's word in your heart. He's
coming again, and this will help to wash
us and get us ready for his coming.
Heat. Heat.